[Music]
my friend Paul Doty asked me if I'd like
to go work at the United States arms
control and disarmament agency in
Washington DC I decided I would focus on
biological weapons so I went to Fort
Detrick to see what we were doing with
biological weapons and I was given a
tour by a quite good immunologist Leroy
Fothergill and we came to a big building
seven stories high and from a distance
you would think it had windows but when
you get up close they were phony windows
and I asked dr. Fothergill what do we do
in there and he said well we have a big
fermenter in there and we make anthrax I
said well why do we do that
he said well biological weapons are a
lot cheaper than nuclear weapons it will
save us money I don't think it took me
very long to realize it hey we don't
want devastating weapons of mass
destruction to be real cheap and save us
money we would like them to be so
expensive that no one can afford them
but us or maybe no one at all it's
ridiculous to what a weapon of mass
destruction
this ultra cheap the more I thought
about it
two things motivated me very strongly
that's just the illogic of it when it
was my science biology that my science
would be perverted in that way but
there's another aspect and that is the
difference between war and peace
biological weapons they could be
responsible for a kind of war
it's totally surreptitious you don't
even know what's happening or you know
what's happening but it's always
happening so for those two reasons my
science and that could erase the
distinction between war and peace could
even change what it means to be human I
felt a strong philosophical desire to
get this thing stopped
[Music]
you
[Music]